liz what's going on i am an independent
contractor
and have found myself to be the
middleman
between the author founder of the
program and her daughter
who is the ceo oh lord on a stick in a
box
you probably can tell where i'm going
with this so i feel like this
this show is brought to you by days of
our lives this has been awesome the
whole show but go ahead
or dawson's creek which is the best go
ahead
i so i was hired by the cta by the ceo
to help her move the company and the
product forward like with technology
social media et cetera all the kinds of
stuff that the author
either doesn't understand doesn't want
or
doesn't or wants to do it her own exact
way
so throw in a very strained
mother-daughter relationship
and it's a recipe for anxiety for me yes
especially especially when i talk to the
ceo
because she reminds me so much of my mom
who
i also have a strange relationship with
that's just a side note
so well i would actually flip that
around my guess is your anxiety comes
from that fractured relationship
that this one reflects not vice versa
but that's a whole other show so
continue
so um they both talk openly about
conflicts and feelings that they have
regarding the other person
and the author gets pretty mad when i
disagree with her about something
and wants me to basically follow blindly
her directions even when they go against
what the ceo has told me
so the reason i contacted you
is to see if you could help me with
setting better boundaries with both of
them without
being rude first of all and keeping my
job because i like my job a lot
and just i i want to get out of the
triangle
i don't know how to do it uh that's such
a great question
um so and just one more thing
um the author still really wants to be
involved in the day-to-day
of course but she really needs to step
back
right so um
it sounds like you have a good
relationship with her daughter is that
fair
so what would it look like for you to go
out for coffee
or i don't know what you're allowed to
do in california but to um
to uh i don't i really don't have a zoom
call
um to talk to her and just say hey
starting off 2021 i'm
i'm caught in the middle of this wonky
relationship with y'all too
i love love this job i love love you
it's getting weird
um can you give me some guidance if you
just approached it head on direct like
that
in a humble kind way what would she say
it's getting weird i like that word
track
and here's why i don't want you to go i
don't i don't want you
if you use words like this sucks or this
is bad or this is wrong
all three may be true but you're talking
about her mom
right and she can talk about her mom but
probably you can't
right correct and also
she gets weird she knows it's weird and
if you call it out in a gentle humble
way
then that's different than an attack
right and then somebody can hear a
gentle humble like you're asking her for
advice
you're not saying that her mom's an
idiot right
right and yeah i think you're right i
would get out of this triangulation at
some point this comes down and you're
the fall guy just so you know
okay a hundred percent chance this ends
badly and you're the one that ends the
worst four
because mom's not going to fire daughter
or she is but it's gonna be your fault
and then you're going to get blamed for
it or vice versa daughter who's running
the company is going to get rid of the
original author
right because that's mom and so you
become the weak link of this triangle
and the whole thing implodes on you
and yikes i never thought about it you
have to be the natural fall guy because
or fall gal here because
they may bicker about each other and not
like each other but that's still a mom
and that's still daughter
and you will never be that yeah right
and so
here's here's a ugly reality check you
may not want
to not have this job it may be awesome
and it may not be in the cards for you
to have it much longer
and then that's not cool or not fun but
that may just be straight up reality
i guess i could see that happening
it's with by your silence it sounds like
you know this is inevitable
right well not really i mean it makes
sense what you say and i
i totally i trust your knowledge and
this type of stuff for sure
but we have had conversations the ceo
and i about
where we both want to see this company
going and
how to get there and but if mom is still
driving
if mom is the author originator she owns
the patent she's the
governor here man we can have all the
dreams
you know what i super want next year two
million
dollars i want that so bad and i want a
pony that can fly because my daughter
would think i
ruled and if i could have like a
life-sized lego thing for my son would
be right like a x-wing one of those star
wars machine things that goes
that'd be awesome too my wife would like
a husband with way more abs than i had
all that would be awesome
um but then there's that reality part
right
and so yeah dude those dreaming
conversations with the ceo are so great
and here's what we could do if mom would
just get out of the way the problem is
mom's not getting out of the way
yeah at least not of our own accord
right
and man you want to see you guys have
had a lot of fires in your area this
year
you want to see a big one watch the
daughter ceo fi
fire her mom who is the original author
of this thing
no thanks right yeah yeah so i again i'm
playing
nuclear option here but i think this
whole thing starts with an honest hey
this thing just feels weird and it feels
like it's getting weirder can you help
me
and um i love your mom i love you
i love love this job and i love the
mission of this company i love where
we're headed
but this is starting to get super weird
for me and i don't know what to do next
and let her coach you and at some point
if it gets super gnarly with mom
then you're able to say i'm just simply
doing like a me and
and ceo talked through this and so we
came up with a game plan here
um and at that point you were
redirecting to the ceo where that those
type
of challenges go anyway is that fair
yeah that's fair so you do me a
humongous i'm having a
i confess i'm having a hard time
believing you
what what's that believe me with i don't
want to oh yeah
i don't want to be the fall guy i i i
want
to not believe me that i'm going to have
2 million dollars next year i'm gonna
have to sell a lot of these ten dollar
books to get two million dollars next
year i've sell a lot of them
right so all that to say it's probably
not gonna happen for me
um maybe you're gonna be the one
you're not i'm just trying to be all
nice and kind you're not you will be the
fall guy 100
and if you feel comfortable enough with
the ceo in that conversation tell her
i don't want to be the fall guy in this
deal i don't want this when this is
going to go south and i don't see a way
where it's not
i'm stuck in the middle here and i love
you both and i love this job and i don't
want to be the person that ends up on
fire here when this thing
crashes and hopefully that ceo's is
um a leader on a woman of character and
she's going to
see this and be like oh my gosh we have
drawn you into our drama
and um it's been a mess since we were a
little i was a little kid
it's still a mess this is not your fight
i'm so sorry i'm gonna do a better job
of
getting you out of the direct fire here
and by the way liz
free advice you didn't even call for
that's what we do on this show free
advice
um worth the price that you pay for it
maybe lean in and start um figuring out
ways you can heal the relationship with
your mom
at least you're part of it she may not
have any interest in wanting to
reconnect or to heal
a lifetime of a messed up relationship
but man
that gives you some peace moving forward
in your life to have that
um that tether reconnected there with
your mom i'd love to see that happen